All right,
welcome back to Computer Vision.
And when I say back,
I took a whole week off, so basically,
I have no idea where we are.
So hopefully you'll be more got
your act together better than I do.
I think last time we were
talking something about
the Lucas-Kanade method of solving for
optical flow or for motion.
And if you remember,
we had this problem with optical flow
that we refer to as
the aperture problem.
The aperture problem was if you
look at a little local area and
you can only tell the motion that is in
the direction of the gradient
perpendicular to the edge.
So, basically to solve that, we had
to compose some form of constraints.
First we did the global constraints.
Then we did the local
constraints of Lucas and Kanade.
And the idea was by having
these local constraints,
we could have more than
one equation per pixel.
And the basic idea was to pretend
that all the pixels were moving
in the same direction in a little,
local neighborhood, so
we would sum up over that window.
We said a five by five window.
You'd have 25 equations per pixel.
And that basically gave us this least
square solution, and we related that to
the whole Harris Corners, where we said
that if the matrix, here A transpose A.
If that matrix was well-conditioned,
which meant we had two decent sized
eigenvalues it meant that the gradient
occurred in various
directions over that window.
And we mentioned how this method
of recovering how something moved
was first proposed by Lukas and
Kanade in 1981.
But, critical to the whole
derivation was the idea that
we use this Taylor series expansion.
That is, that we could approximate
how something would move or
how much the intensity would change
by essentially fitting a planar ramp,
that was the first-order
derivative approximation.
Fitting a planar ramp to a point,
and then as the point would move,
the intensity would change according
to the slope on that ramp.
But, of course, there were certain
assumptions built into Lucas-Kanade that
were sometimes problematic.
So the main assumption was
that the pixel hasn't moved,
didn't change it's color,
didn't change it's intensity.
So if brightness constancy doesn't hold,
then you have to do something
in terms of feature detection.
Finding a feature from
one place to another, and
we've already talk about doing SIFT
detections and characterization,
in order to do these, these matches.
And we can combine those.
In fact, we're not going to but
I'll talk at the very end
about how you can combine dense
estimation with SIFT estimation.
The other thing we said is that possibly
a bunch of points are moving one way and
another points are moving another way.
So, in that area, it,
within a window you don't actually have
all the points moving
in the same direction.
And you have to solve that
with a motion segmentation.
We mentioned that, we'll actually go
over, sort of, a mechanism of doing
that, not at the end of this lecture,
but at the end of the, the next one.
Oh, these aren't lectures,
these are videos, so
that makes them sound
like they're more fun